und jetzt das heute journal
in allen einen guten Samstagabend 25
Fragen hatte der bayerische
Ministerpräsident seinem Stellvertreter
gestellt 25 Fragen hat der beantwortet
auch wenn wir noch nicht wissen wie und
jetzt sagt Hubert Aiwanger sollten alle
wieder zur Tagesarbeit zurückkehren er
spricht aber gleichzeitig auch von einer
Hexenjagd gegen seine Person und es
sieht so aus als ob er mit der Affäre um
ein widerliches Flugblatt voller
Judenhass auch Wahlkampf machen will
Alexander Pool berichtet
das Aubinger Herbstfest bei München
eigentlich ein ganz normaler
Wahlkampftermin für Markus Söder doch
heute warten alle auf eine Entscheidung
zum Fall eiwanger
Fragen beantwortet wir machen weiter
einen schönen Tag sagt und lächelt den
Fall Aiwanger erstmal weg dann irgendwo
im Getümmel wenigstens eine kurze
Antwort alles wird sauber geprüft alles
wird sauber geprüft fünf Wochen vor der
Landtagswahl in Bayern ist Hubert
Aiwanger für Söder zu einer Belastung
geworden was nun nachdem alwanger den
Fragenkatalog der CSU zu der
antisemitischen Herzschrift beantwortet
hat bei der CSU Basis sind die Meinungen
zu Hubert Aiwanger differenziert
sein mai am Ende ich glaube zwischen
jugendzünde und antisemitischen
Äußerungen ist halt doch ein großer
Unterschied ich würde mit einwanger
weitermachen weitermachen das wenn
Hubert Aiwanger auch der bayerische
Wirtschaftsminister heute zu Gast in
Hessen zu seinem freie wählerpublikum
sagt er kein Wort zum Flugblatt oder den
anderen Anschuldigungen stattdessen ein
Zeitungsinterview darin spricht Aiwanger
von einer Hexenjagd
ich finde das Wort Hexenjagd
unangebracht ich kann verstehen er fühlt
sich unschuldig er fühlt sich nicht
ordentlich behandelt trotzdem hat er ja
auch eine gewisse Schuld eingeräumt also
insofern muss ihm dann auch klar sein es
ist keine Hexenjagd es sind Recherchen
es ist Wahlkampf ja da würde ich sagen
damit muss man in der Politik dann auch
umgehen können vor der Entscheidung so
dass zu seiner politischen Zukunft
scheint Aiwanger gelassen ich weiß nicht
zu welcher Einschätzung der
Ministerpräsident kommt aber ich sehe
nach meinen Antworten überhaupt keinen
Grund für einen Rücktritt oder eine
Entlassung
die meisten hier in Hessen denken genau
so im Moment haben wir immer noch die
Unschuldsvermutung hier in Deutschland
bin ich der Ansicht ohne vorurteilung
sollte hier nicht stattfinden es sollte
auf keinen Fall zurücktreten aber er
hätte von Anfang an viel offener eben
reden müssen die Opposition in Bayern
fordert heute Offenheit von Markus Söder
ich verstehe wenn Markus Söder sich
jetzt etwas Zeit nimmt für eine schwere
Entscheidung aber ich finde dass die
Fragen und vor allem auch die Antworten
natürlich veröffentlicht werden müssen
weil so eine Entscheidung kann jetzt
nicht einfach im Hinterzimmer getroffen
werden wann Söder entscheidet ist nach
wie vor offen
bringen wir heute unseren
bayern-korrespondenten mit dazu Stefan
leifert genannt Stefan wie stellt sich
denn der Ministerpräsident jetzt den
Zeitrahmen für seine Entscheidung vor er
hatte ja doch sehr stark gedrängt und
morgen ist er im ZDF sommerinterview
ja so ist es und das wird morgen im
frühen Nachmittag aufgezeichnet also wer
sich heute im Umfeld von Markus Söder
umgehört hat der hat sehr deutlich zu
spüren bekommen dass es nicht nur keine
Entscheidung gibt über den Fall
einfacher sondern auch noch gar keinen
wirklich klaren Zeitplan wenn es noch
eine schnelle Entscheidung geben soll
dann könnte das Ganze noch morgen
Vormittag vonstatten gehen danach kommen
dann erst einmal ein paar Termine die
das ganze verhindern würden darunter
auch das hätte er sommerinterview danach
könnte es dann wieder Montag Nachmittag
oder Dienstag werden das ist einfach
eine Entscheidung die aus Markus so dass
sich unglaublich schwierig ist
vielleicht die schwerste Entscheidung
seines Lebens weil er vor zwei
Alternativen steht die beide mit
unglaublich großen Risiken behaftet sind
sollte er bei Hubert awanger bleiben
dann würde er sich möglicherweise dem
Vorwurf mangelnden Aufklärung Willens
aussetzen denn Markus Söder hat die
Latte ja sehr sehr hoch gehängt hat von
einem widerlichen Flugblatt gesprochen
davon dass jetzt zweifelsfrei aufgeklärt
werden müssen und jeder Zweifel der am
Ende ein Hubert einfacher wäre dann auch
ein Problem für Markus Söder sollte er
ihn am Ende entlassen steht Markus Söder
nicht nur ohne Koalitionspartner da für
die CSU sondern auch ohne eine
Wahlkampfstrategie denn die war bisher
in den ganzen letzten Monaten allein
darauf ausgerichtet eine Fortsetzung mit
den Freien Wählern zu betreiben Stefan
ganz kurz noch werden wir denn jetzt
auch erfahren was in diesen 25 Fragen an
und Antworten von Aiwanger drin steht
erstmal nicht das bleibt größtmögliche
Verschlusssache hier in Bayern auch wenn
es am Anfang mal hieß die Fragen werden
veröffentlicht werden sicherlich jetzt
nicht mehr vor der Entscheidung wir
haben mit einem Freien Wähler gesprochen
der diese Frage Liste kennt er hat
gesagt dass sein sehr faire und sehr
naheliegende Fragen dass das Ganze so
lange dauert hat zum einen den Grund
dass die CSU jetzt ein bisschen Zeit
gewinnen möchte um an der Basis sich
umzuhören denn dort ist das Meinungsbild
wohl doch nicht so klar wie man am
Anfang gedacht hat
und das könnte den Ausschlag dafür geben
dass es wohl doch keine schnelle
Entscheidung Morgen gibt sondern erst in
den nächsten Tagen vielleicht bis Mitte
nächster Woche herzlichen Dank
und die Nachrichten jetzt im Überblick
beginnen in der Bundespolitik und mit
dir Hanna auf die
derung ep-bundestagsfraktion den Rück
Bauer zu stoppen hat Bundeskanzler
Scholz heute mit einer klaren Absage
reagiert das Thema Atomkraft sei in
Deutschland Zitat ein totes Pferd sagte
Scholz in Deutschland Funk der Ausstieg
sei gesetzlich erfolgt zu einem
staatlich subventionierten
industriestrompreis äußerte sich der
Kanzler erneut skeptisch es sei unklar
wo die benötigten Milliarden für die
Finanzierung weggenommen werden sollten
erklärte Scholz
das
Bundesverkehrsministerium will den
Ausbau privater lade Infrastruktur für
E-Autos vorantreiben deshalb soll es ab
dem 26 September eine neue staatliche
Förderung geben der Kauf einer
Solaranlage eines Speichers und einer
Ladestation soll mit bis zu 10.200 Euro
unterstützt werden voraussetzung ist
dass alle drei Komponenten zusammen neu
gekauft werden zudem muss ein
Elektroauto bereits vorhanden oder
bestellt sein anträge können bei der KfW
Bank gestellt werden das Förderprogramm
hat ein Volumen von 500 Millionen Euro
CDU-Chef März hat sich offen für eine
Diskussion über eine Anhebung des
Spitzensteuersatzes gezeigt dies wird
aus Teilen seiner Partei gefordert der
Satz bei 42 oder 45 prozentige sei nicht
entscheidend sagte März der Frankfurter
Allgemeinen Sonntagszeitung wichtig sei
eine Entlastung der Mittelschicht die
Belastungskurve müssen abgeflacht werden
in Israel sind bei Zusammenstößen
zwischen der Polizei und Migranten aus
Eritrea mehr als 150 Menschen verletzt
worden vor der eritreischen Botschaft in
Tel Aviv hatten Gegner der autoritären
Regierung des afrikanischen Landes
demonstriert und gerieten dabei mit
Regierungsanhängern und der Polizei
aneinander in Deutschland hatte es im
Juli bei einem Eritrea Festival
ebenfalls Ausschreitungen gegeben
Geschichte wiederholt sich nicht und
manchmal scheint es doch so wer über die
ersten Proteste in Syrien gegen
Machthaber basharalassat berichtet hat
wird das nie mehr vergessen das war 2011
damals kam Menschen aus Syrien über die
staubige Grenze Richtung Jordanien mit
vor Angst geweiteten Augen und konnten
kaum sprechen weil sie unter Schock
standen ob der grausame Reaktion des
Regimes auf die ersten vorsichtigen
Demonstrationen wir wissen heute es war
der Beginn des syrischen Bürgerkriegs
mit mehreren hunderttausend Toten über
13 Millionen Flüchtlingen und bitterer
Armut die UNO schätzt dass die Hälfte
der Menschen in Syrien nicht mehr genug
zu essen bekommt
das ist ein Grund für neue Proteste
jetzt gegen die Assad Herrschaft sie
wollen nicht verstummen obwohl alle
wissen dass jede Kritik am System
lebensgefährlich ist anders heißt
verschwindet dieser Mann dass diese
Bilder uns erreichen ist nicht
selbstverständlich sie bezeugen die
größten Proteste in von Assad
kontrollierten Gebieten seit Jahren hier
skandieren sie die Menschen wollen den
Sturz des Regimes es sind die Slogans
von damals von 2011 von der syrischen
Revolution die in einem blutigen
Bürgerkrieg mündete 15 Tage laufen nun
die Proteste gegen Assad im Süden
Syriens bisher friedlich doch gestern
Nachmittag wurde ins Raider das Internet
weitestgehend eingestellt das bedeute
nichts Gutes an die Einheimischen aber
es gibt kein zurück mehr doch der Reihe
nach sueder der 18 August sie rufen
Bazar hau ab die Menschen hier sind
sauer denn wenige Tage zuvor wurden die
Subventionen für Benzin aufgehoben die
Währung komplett wertlos schon jetzt
leben neun von zehn Syrern in Armut
die Menschen können nicht mehr sie
können nicht mehr atmen sie sehen wie
die Preise steigen ohne Ende
Machthaber Assad lässt die täglichen
Proteste bisher gewähren obwohl Bilder
von ihm verbrannt werden eine seiner
Partei zentralen angegriffen wurde in
den sozialen Medien melden sich nun
seine Unterstützer mit einer klaren
Drohung
ich warne euch bald wird es einen Besuch
geben ich sage euch nicht wer aber da
wird er sehr bald zu euch nach sueda
kommen
unterdessen in den sogenannten
rebellengebieten die Gegenden die nicht
von Assad kontrolliert werden hier ruft
die Koalition der arabischen Stämme zu
einer notkonferenz ihre Stimme hat am
ganzen Land Gewicht sie unterstützen den
Protest
an die in den Straßen von zu jeder wir
sind bei euch wir stehen vor und hinter
euch unsere Hände in euren unser Blut
ist eures
es ist die Zusage zu kämpfen sollte
Assad versuchen die Demonstration blutig
nieder zu schlagen
zurück in sueder gestern Vormittag die
Vorbereitungen für den größten Protest
seit Jahren laufen diese
Politikwissenschaftlerin ist eigens aus
Damaskus angereist wie viele hier
ich rufe alle Syrer aus allen Städten
auf uns zu folgen das könnte unser
historischer Moment werden entweder
jetzt oder nie in meinem Nacken
fest steht obwohl der Druck auf suay
dazu nimmt das Internet heute weiter von
der Regierung blockiert wird die
Demonstranten wollen weitermachen
[Applaus]
zu den Lottozahlen an diesem Samstag die
lauten 22 25 27 28 34 47 Superzahl 0
alle Angaben wie immer ohne Gewähr
und jetzt der Blick auf die sommerlichen
Wetteraussichten Morgen viel Sonne im
Norden und Osten auch einige Wolken aber
nur im Südosten vereinzelt Schauer
Höchstwerte zwischen 20 und 29 Grad in
den kommenden Tagen ruhiges
Spätsommerwetter meist sonnig bei
Höchsttemperaturen zwischen 22 und 31
Grad
wir senden hier aus Mainz für
Deutschland gucken heute aber mal quasi
aus dem Fenster auf eine Region direkt
vor der Tür die international bekannt
ist für historische Stätten Denkmäler
und vor allem ihren Wein eine Region in
der heute Abend im Kloster Eberbach ein
Festival zu Ende geht das in diesem Jahr
die erfolgreichste Saison feiert in
seiner 36-jährigen Geschichte noch nie
wurden so viele Karten verkauft für
164 Konzerte an 28 Spielstätten im
Rheingau und heute Abend einen Maestro
am Pult der als dienstältester Spitzen
Dirigent der Welt gilt und als einer den
das Publikum liebt überall Peter Theisen
dem staunenden Auge wird hier immer
etwas geboten der Rheingau mit seinen
berühmten Burgen Schlössern und Klöstern
doch jeden Sommer bietet der auch
Hochgenuss für die Ohren an
spektakulären Orten zwischen Rhein und
Reben beim Rheingau Musikfestival
ich liebe diese Landschaft und wenn man
dann da oben steht mitten im Weinberg
mit Blick auf den Fluss und dann dort
auch noch ein Konzert spielen darf das
ist spektakulär etwas Besonderes für uns
Musiker und ganz anders als in einem
nicht zu inspirierenden Betonbau zu
spielen
vielleicht ist es also auch diese ganz
besondere Atmosphäre die Musiker von
Weltrang wie Jan lieschewski und das
London philharmonik Orchestra zu solchen
musikalischen Sternstunden antreibt
[Musik]
er hat dieses Festival vor 35 Jahren ins
Leben gerufen ganz klein hat es
angefangen dieses Jahr bricht es alle
Besucherrekorde
nach der corona-zeit glauben wir dass
die Leute einfach wieder rausholen wir
wollen wieder etwas erleben Sie wollen
Musik hören sie wollen keinen Streaming
sehen ich glaube das ist einer der
Hauptgründe dafür dass wir dieses Jahr
wirklich so erfolgreich waren
viele Künstler sind im Rheingau seit
Jahrzehnten treu Herbert Blomstedt etwa
Dirigenten Legende heute leitet er das
Abschlusskonzert mit 96 und doch voller
einzigartiger Energie
[Musik]
wie schafft er das bloß
halten in fünf Minuten
krank aber wenn das mit Musik gefühlt
ist dann können sie noch noch zwei
Stunden halten das ist die Qualität der
Musik das ist eine eine geistige
Infusion
es ist das letzte von 164 Konzerten zum
Schluss spielt das Leipziger
Gewandhausorchester unter einem sanften
Meister Dirigenten Bruckner 7 Sinfonie
[Musik]
und so feiert man in der Basilika des
Klosters Eberbach ein weiteres Hochamt
der klassischen Musik
ach toll und wir waren dabei zumindest
hier im Fernsehen und damit sagen wir
Ihnen danke für heute und gern bis
morgen und die nächsten Nachrichten gibt
es hier gegen 0.20 mit Christopher
Wehrmann
[Musik]